I really want to start with congrats on
the movie
um I thought this was very well done and
it made me very angry and therefore it
was effective
um uh but before we get into talking
about it I like throwing a curve at the
beginning
um if someone is actually never seen
anything that you've done before uh
acting wise
um what is the first thing you'd like
them watching and why
I might go with my first real role in a
movie which was a movie called Beautiful
Girls
that is one of my favorites still and
you know you never forget your first it
was my first real Hollywood experience
so it has a very special place in my my
memory and my heart and I I'm really
proud of it I think it's a really strong
movie so uh that's one I would I might
recommend first uh you know what I was
first of all I loved that film and I
love that and we talked about I love
that scene when you guys are in the bar
and you're playing uh is it Sweet
Caroline on the piano or yeah yeah it's
a and it's also just a great film but I
was gonna say a similar thing for me is
the first real role that I ever did uh a
film called Crown Heights which is um
who I played at Trinidadian so I had
like a Trinidadian accent the entire
time and it was um it's an Amazon film I
produced it as well so I think that's
the one to to to dive in on if there was
a first to watch individual question for
each of you I'm going to start with
namdi with you
um what's cooler catching a interception
in the NFL or being in a movie with Noah
Jessica and Eddie
[Music]
they both share equal value
um in my heart
is that okay does that work
a nice diplomatic answer let me help you
out I said but that's a singular moment
that moment to catch that's a singular
moment nothing can touch that I would
guess if if you're if you won't be
offended not at all yes
yeah that is the answer
that's my answer too and I never I never
even played eam there there's there's
there's nothing really like that feeling
um
of doing that in the NFL I will never
experience it I will just live
vicariously through the smile you know
um Noah I obviously loved your work on
the Americans um is it sort of do you
miss making the show or do you sort of
feel like um because now that you've
wrapped you have more time to take on a
role like this which maybe you couldn't
have done
um when you were making the show I I
miss the people
I missed the family of the show you know
I miss seeing the my we were together
for five six years and uh you know we
you get very close over that stretch of
time and that intensity of work so uh
and I'm we're still in touch to some
degree you know but I missed the the
as I miss on every job that goes away
eventually I mean I've never done one
for as long as the Americans so it's the
most resonant in the deepest in a way
but uh I don't I don't know if I missed
I mean I think we told our story and I
don't think there's more to tell so I
don't feel like any desire to to do Stan
Beaman anymore but I do miss the people
jumping into why I get to talk to the
two of you it is um I can't imagine what
it was like I'm I'm not sure if you knew
the story but what is it like reading a
script like this and realizing this is a
true story and it's probably still
happening you know that people are just
getting shuffled to uh other hospitals
you know what I mean yeah it's
horrifying I mean it's just it's just a
horrifying
infuriating
incomprehensible reality and then the
most Modern Nation most technologically
advanced the richest nation in the
history of the world
we don't have health care as human
rights we have it as a for-profit
business
uh
it just seems Criminal
in this case literally I I completely
agree with you one of the things that I
thought the film does very effective is
that it doesn't focus on Charlie's
motivations it's not trying to get into
the you know showing the violence of it
all it is about
um exploring the humanity and you know
um Jessica's anyway could you sort of
talk about that aspect of the film that
it's not the typical story where you're
you know what I mean most films you
focus on the villain it's just something
that uh Tobias has talked about a lot
our director just in terms of um
wanting to focus on the heroes and the
story versus focusing on the villain so
obviously when the film starts you're
gonna find out and know that this is the
guy he's the guy that's that's done uh
that's committed these crimes
um but we're not gonna get into his life
and sort of lionize him in some sort of
way and pay that much attention to him
we want to talk about the heroes that
brought him down and that really
um uncovered what this institution was
trying to cover up and I thought that
was very I thought that was heroic in
its own sense as a filmmaker to choose
that route versus the salacious route of
just sticking with the serial killer
which I'm sure tons of people would have
wanted to see for both of you I love
learning about how actors like to work
so let's use an example if you don't
mind from this film say you have an
important scene on a Monday morning
something dramatic or emotional that
that you know might be a little
challenging how early on are you
actually getting ready for that scene
and thinking about it and breaking down
how you might want to do it
um because I've spoken to some actors
that say they're getting ready weeks in
advance and others were like it's
Saturday morning
2018
when I started
I mean I don't think you can ever be
over prepared
I I mean the caveat there is that what
what preparation means can be can be a
wide variance so I don't mean prepared
like knowing exactly how you're gonna do
the scene I think I think you can be
over prepared if you're if you have a
result in mind
but I think you can never be over
prepared in terms of
understanding another human being
how long does it take you to understand
another it's never about the scene it's
always about the whole person so I think
it's a mistake to think oh wow Monday's
a big scene I better prepare for Monday
Monday's just a day in the life of your
character maybe big things happen on
that day but and like in real life you
never need to prepare to be yourself you
are yourself but you know we're playing
people that we're not so there's there's
another there's an unlimited amount of
preparation
that can go into the full understanding
of another human a lifetime you know so
that's why the great roles are Revisited
years and years later if some actors
play the same role over the course of 40
years you take a Shakespeare character
you can revisit that role forever so
that's that's my point of view uh uh
there's no such thing as being over
prepared
agreed I agree
oh okay I thought you were going to say
more about that no I I agree completely
I don't know that there's I mean I can
try to say something else but the
preparation the preparation for the role
starts when you get the project and so
if there's a big scene that's coming up
on a Monday it's just like Noah said
you've you're preparing for that
character and you've done that the
moment that you've gotten the material
you're preparation as an actor starts
way before that so there are little
tools that you can throw in here and
there on that day that can help you but
for the role it's when you get the
material it's not you know the day of
the big scene I know I know what you
mean on that note I got to stop I'm just
going to say seriously congrats and
thank you so much for your time yeah
thank you very much